Rishi sunak arriving in Paris promising
a new beginning his predecessor couldn't
say if Emmanuel macron was a true Ally
he's trying to defend or Foe prime
minister
this new prime minister in little doubt
the warmest of handshakes in the
courtyard of the Elysee Palace this the
first summit of its kind since 2018 both
leaders Keen to show the world that this
is a diplomatic bromance
a brief pose for the cameras but soon
Alone Together the president and prime
minister spent an hour in talks with no
aides or officials in the room
top of the agenda small boats crossing
the channel in the last decade the UK
has given over 250 million pounds in
funding to French authorities and they
still keep coming Rishi sunak believes
his predecessors took the wrong approach
If we're honest the relationship between
our two countries has had its challenges
but I believe today's meeting does Mark
A New Beginning
this means concrete action from the
French to help stop small boats
we're announcing a new Detention Center
in northern France a new Command Center
bringing our enforcement teams together
in one place for the first time and an
extra 500 new offices patrolling French
beaches all underpinned by more drones
and other surveillance technologies that
will help ramp up the interception rate
the small print he didn't say on stage
that means nearly half a billion more
funding to French authorities over the
next three years the president's tone
warm but says to return migrants to the
EU Britain must work well with Brussels
now not an agreement between UK and
France but an agreement between Yuki and
the EU
because Dublin agreement are no more in
a situation to be implemented so this is
something now to be negotiated
we're actually seeing that closed this
Summit declaring the Anton was renewed
and he certainly succeeded in
transforming the tone of the
relationship with the UK's closest
neighbors but he needs to convince the
country and his party that this is the
right approach that collaboration
doesn't involve more compromise than
confrontation which was the way Boris
Johnson and Liz trust did it and that
has been made Harder by the fact he's
just written the check to the French for
half a billion pounds
the Pomp and platitudes of a summit
leave big questions and answered how
will the Detention Center work
will more money finally mean fewer
Crossings
Rishi sunax reset continues next stop
the United States being popular with
fellow leaders doesn't mean votes at
home however for that grand promises
need to come good and quickly Sam coat
Sky News Paris